This story is always different, but it's also always the same. The blue-blooded Yankee graduates from Yale, moves to Texas, starts talking like a good ol' boy, turns himself into an oil man, and after that, into President of the United States. The Czechoslovakian pencil-necked geek from Pittsburgh named Andy Warhol moves to New York, dresses in black, becomes a darling of the rich and glamorous. The nice Jewish boy from Minnesota affects an oaky twang, picks up a guitar, renames himself for Welsh poet Dylan Thomas and-- you know this story.
这个故事总是千差万别，但也总是如出一辙。名门望族的洋基人从耶鲁毕业，搬到德克萨斯，开始学着像个乡下老粗一样说话，把自己变成石油大亨，后来又成了美国总统。匹兹堡一个叫安迪·沃霍尔的捷克裔瘦弱极客搬到纽约，一身黑衣，成了富豪名流眼中的宠儿。来自明尼苏达的犹太好男孩学着一口橡木味的腔调，拿起吉他，以威尔士诗人迪伦·托马斯的名字为自己改名，然后——你知道这个故事。
One thing that makes our country different from all of the other ones is this idea that it's our birthright that we can recreate ourselves as someone who we prefer to be, sell everything off, move somewhere else, start a new life. This tendency is so deep in American culture that we have an entire industry, a self-help industry, telling us how to transform ourselves into someone new. And usually, we see this as a positive thing. But what happens if you're too good at it, at throwing everything off, starting over from scratch?
我们国家与众不同的地方在于这样一个观念：我们有权重新塑造自己，成为我们想成为的人，变卖一切，搬到别处，开始新生活。这种倾向在美式文化中根深蒂固，以至于我们有整个行业——自助产业——告诉我们如何将自己蜕变为新人。通常，我们认为这是件好事。但如果你太擅长这样做，太擅长抛弃一切、从零开始，会发生什么呢？
Over the course of his life, Keith Aldrich was a child of the Depression in Oklahoma, then a preacher-in-training in booming California, an aspiring Hollywood actor. In the '50s, he remade himself as a self-styled Beat writer, then as a man in a gray flannel suit. In the '60s, he became part of the New York literati, then went through a hippie phase, moved to the suburbs for '70s-era partying, Ice Storm, John Updike novel kind of life.
基思·奥尔德里奇一生中，曾是俄克拉荷马州大萧条时期的孩子，随后是在加州蓬勃发展时期的预备牧师、雄心勃勃的好莱坞演员。在50年代，他将自己重塑为自封的“垮掉派”作家，随后又变成一个身穿灰色法兰绒西装的人。在60年代，他成了纽约文坛的一员，接着经历了一段嬉皮士时期，搬到郊区过起了70年代派对、如约翰·厄普代克小说《冰风暴》般的生活。
When the Moral Majority helped put Ronald Reagan into office in the '80s, he changed again, became a born-again Christian. Not only is his life a history of most of the major cultural shifts of the second half of the 20th century in this country, it's a case study in the question, what happens if you're too good at transforming yourself, at this part of our national character.
当“道德多数派”在80年代帮助罗纳德·里根入主白宫时，他又变了，成了一名重生基督徒。他的生活不仅是本国20世纪下半叶大多数主要文化转变的历史，也是一个案例研究：如果你太擅长自我改造，太擅长这种国民性格的一部分，会发生什么？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And today, we are devoting our entire program to the story of this man's life, as told by one of his nine children, Gillian Aldrich. Keith Aldrich married five times. He left one set of wife and kids after another at most of the major turning points in his life. When he died in 1993, for the first time ever, eight of the nine kids got together in the same place, at his funeral, and talked about what sort of man he was. And it was then that they realized that they all knew different versions of their father.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们将整个节目献给这个人的生平故事，由他的九个孩子之一——吉莉安·奥尔德里奇讲述。基思·奥尔德里奇结过五次婚。在他人生的大多数重要转折点，他一个接一个地抛弃了妻子和孩子。1993年他去世时，九个孩子中的八个第一次聚在一起参加他的葬礼，谈论他是个什么样的人。那时他们才意识到，他们每个人眼中的父亲版本都不一样。
And so a couple years after that, Gillian Aldrich, his sixth child, set out to reconcile all these different accounts. She left her home in New York City to go out and interview all of her half siblings about her father's life. Here's her story.
在那之后的几年里，他的第六个孩子吉莉安·奥尔德里奇着手调和这些不同的说法。她离开纽约的家，去采访了所有的同父异母兄弟姐妹，探寻父亲的生平。这就是她的故事。
When I started this trip, I saw my dad as the quintessential restless American, constantly on the move in his quest for his dreams. I knew there was a dark side to all this, people left behind, marriages busted. But still there was some part of his quest that seemed heroic. I'm sure he saw it that way too.
刚开始这段旅程时，我眼中的父亲是一个典型的躁动不安的美国人，为了梦想不断奔波。我知道这一切都有阴暗的一面：被抛下的人、破裂的婚姻。但他的追求中仍有某种似乎英雄主义的东西。我相信他自己也是这么看的。
I was a very good boy when I was a kid, a very good boy.
我小时候是个非常好的孩子，非常好的孩子。
This is how my father told his own story. It's a church testimony recorded 14 years before he died.
这就是我父亲讲述自己故事的方式。这是他在去世前14年录下的一段教会见证。
And my great ambition was to be a preacher, like me Uncle Floyd. And I [? blessed ?] that to my Lord. On the other hand, not so easily seen, there was this rebellious kid inside.
我最大的抱负是成为一名牧师，就像我叔叔弗洛伊德一样。我把这一点向主祈祷。另一方面，在内心深处，还有一个不那么容易被察觉的叛逆小子。
1929 to 1953, age of innocence. My dad grew up in the Church of Christ during the Depression in Oklahoma. His family moved to California after Pearl Harbor, so that his father could get work welding on the ships to help the war effort. My father got a scholarship to a Christian school, Pepperdine College. He was married in the same year to his high school sweetheart.
1929年至1953年，纯真年代。我父亲在俄克拉荷马州大萧条时期的基督教会中长大。珍珠港事件后，为了让父亲能去造船厂做焊工支援战争，他们全家搬到了加州。父亲获得了佩珀代因大学基督学校的奖学金。同年，他与高中时的恋人结婚。
I'm Shelly. I was from the first marriage. I was born in Whittier, California. Dad was young.
我是雪莉。我是第一段婚姻生的。我出生在加州惠蒂尔。爸爸当时很年轻。
I started my trip at Shelly's house in Eugene, Oregon, where I see my half sisters from my dad's first marriage. There's Shelly and there's Becky, who's up from San Francisco for the weekend with her daughter. I'm surprised to be included in their family weekend. We barely know each other, and don't have much in common outside of our father. Yet we spend three days going whitewater rafting and sitting down to big family meals.
我的旅程始于雪莉在俄勒冈州尤金的家，我在那里见到了父亲第一次婚姻中的同父异母姐妹。那是雪莉，还有贝基，她这周末从旧金山带着女儿过来。我很惊讶能加入她们的家庭周末。我们几乎不认识彼此，除了父亲外没什么共同点。然而我们一起度过了三天，去漂流，坐在一起吃丰盛的家宴。
Becky's 50 and Shelly's 48. They're both adamantly devoted to their families. And Shelly's a fundamentalist Christian who's home-schooled all her kids in the belief that parents can and should do better than any school. Still, we're amazingly comfortable with each other. We sit in Shelly's living room and talk into the night about who our father was.
贝基50岁，雪莉48岁。她们都坚定地忠于自己的家庭。雪莉是个原教旨主义基督徒，她在家教育所有孩子，坚信父母能做得比任何学校都好，也应该这样做。尽管如此，我们在一起相处得非常自在。我们坐在雪莉的客厅里，通宵谈论我们的父亲是谁。
He was going to be a preacher. He was going to be a Church of Christ preacher. So he had it all planned out. In the Church of Christ community, that was kind of the highest social status was to be a preacher in the church.
他曾立志成为一名牧师。他打算成为一名基督教会的牧师。他把一切都计划好了。在基督教会社区，成为牧师是最高的社会地位。
I know my mom said, she told me that even though he was 18 when they got married, she said he wasn't like he was 18. He kind of ran the youth group at church. He was the most influential. His father was influential. And he was always very sure of himself, very confident about who he was, where he was going. He was highly respected, even at 18.
我妈跟我说过，虽然他们结婚时他才18岁，但他说他看起来不像18岁。他在教会里负责青年团契。他是最有影响力的人。他父亲也很有影响力。他总是非常自信，清楚自己是谁，要去向何方。即使在18岁时，他就已经备受尊敬。
He was 18 when they got married. And she was 20 years old. And they were just starting out, of course. And they had a little apartment over somebody's garage.
他们结婚时他18岁，她20岁。当然，他们刚刚起步。他们在别人的车库上面有个小公寓。
This is Becky.
这是贝基。
Unfortunately before their plans, they had me.
不幸的是，在他们的计划实现之前，有了我。
I think that had a major effect on his relationship with my mother and their relationship with each other, and how he saw his life unfolding. I'm sure it really bothered him that he saw his possibilities limited by the fact that he had these three children, and he was only 23 years old.
我认为这对父亲和我母亲的关系、他们彼此的关系以及他对自己人生发展的看法产生了重大影响。我相信他对自己的人生可能性因这三个孩子而受限感到非常困扰，毕竟他才23岁。
And so Dad made a choice, the same choice he would repeat over and over for the rest of his life. He simply changed his mind about who he was going to be. He began studying drama, throwing himself into school plays with the same fervor he'd had for being a preacher.
于是爸爸做出了一个选择，一个他在余生中将不断重复的选择。他只是改变了对自己身份的设想。他开始学习表演，并以曾经想当牧师时那般狂热投入到学校剧团中。
It was costly to him, I think, to be involved in drama. He was good at it, but I think it got out of hand for him. As you study the history of drama, it gets out of hand for a lot of people. So that changed his focus and certainly changed my parents relationship.
我认为，投身表演对他来说代价高昂。他演得很好，但我认为这对他来说失控了。如果你研究戏剧史，会发现很多人都失控了。所以这改变了他的重心，当然也改变了我父母的关系。
So how did it break up, the marriage with your mom. What happened? It seems like it could be something that you do and you stay happily married.
那么，你妈妈那段婚姻是怎么破裂的？发生了什么？这看起来本来可以是那种你们可以维持幸福婚姻的事情。
Oh, sure. But Dad was having affairs with women. That doesn't go over well.
噢，当然。但爸爸在外面有婚外情。那可不是什么好处理的事情。
They soon divorced. The three kids, Becky, Shelly, and Alan, didn't really see their father much for the next 15 years. And when I try to get Becky and Shelly to tell me more about the person our father was when they were children, they can't. He left too early for them to remember.
他们很快离婚了。三个孩子——贝基、雪莉和艾伦，在接下来的15年里没怎么见过父亲。当我试着让贝基和雪莉告诉我更多关于父亲在她们童年时的情况时，她们做不到。他离开得太早了，她们没什么记忆。
This is nice. There's a little hill there. We could sit on the mound.
这挺好的。那边有个小山坡。我们可以在土丘上坐坐。
Oh yeah.
噢，是啊。
On my last day in Eugene, Becky, Shelly, and I go on a walk together in the park next to Shelly's house. Shelly tells me that Dad's abandonment is one of the reasons she's devoted herself so fully to her kids.
在尤金的最后一天，贝基、雪莉和我一起在雪莉家旁边的公园散步。雪莉告诉我，父亲的抛弃是她如此全心全意投身于自己孩子的原因之一。
He rejected me. As a child, he left me. He didn't care for me. He didn't send money to my mother to support me. I guess it was when I started having my own children that I started thinking, how could you? How could you have done this to me? I'm committed to my children. Why weren't you committed to me?
他拒绝了我。小时候他抛弃了我。他不关心我。他没有寄钱给母亲抚养我。我想，当我开始有了自己的孩子，我才开始想：你怎么能这样？你怎么能对我做这种事？我对我的孩子尽心尽力。为什么你不对我尽心尽力？
Their feeling about that is so different from mine.
她们对此的感受与我截然不同。
I remember enough to know that as Dad did, he would be involved in our lives as it fit his--
我记得足够多，我知道爸爸做事的逻辑是：他只会在合适的时候参与我们的生活——
As it fit his schedule.
只要符合他的日程安排。
Yeah, as it was convenient for him. The man that we've been describing, does he sound familiar to you? And if so, in what way?
是的，只要对他来说方便就行。我们刚才描述的那个人，你听起来熟悉吗？如果是，是以什么方式熟悉？
Yeah. You know what, I feel like I'm trying to sort of mythologize Dad as an artist, or the creative part of Dad.
是啊。你知道吗，我觉得我是在试图将爸爸神化为一位艺术家，或者爸爸身上有创造力的一面。
I talked about Dad following his dreams, how that gave me the courage to try new things. But it wasn't the kind of argument where anyone convinces anyone else. I ask Shelly if she can see what I saw in him, outside of her experience as an abandoned daughter.
我说过爸爸在追逐梦想，那如何给了我尝试新鲜事物的勇气。但这并不是那种能说服别人的论点。我问雪莉，撇开作为被抛弃女儿的经历，她能否看到我眼中的他。
No, I don't. If you're saying at the cost of your family, I think that's inexcusable. I think that's hideous. I think if you make a commitment to someone, you should keep it.
不，我看不到。如果你说那是以牺牲家庭为代价，我认为那是不可原谅的。我认为那是丑陋的。如果你对某人做出了承诺，你就应该信守。
No, I think that to try to say that because Dad was talented, that that gave him some kind of license to marry women and abandon them is ludicrous, of course not. Each of us has a responsibility to live a life accountable to some kind of righteousness or value, even if you don't believe in God. And certainly, that doesn't include hurting people. No, I see nothing noble in his pursuit of his dreams, if that's what you want to call it. I spit upon it.
不，我认为试图说因为爸爸有天赋，就给了他某种娶妻生子又抛弃她们的许可，这很荒唐，当然不是。每个人都有责任过一种对某种正义或价值负责的生活，即使你不信奉上帝。当然，这绝不包括伤害他人。不，我看不出他追求梦想有什么高尚可言，如果那也叫梦想的话。我对此不屑一顾。
1953 to 1963, Beat in a gray flannel suit.
1953年至1963年，身着灰色法兰绒西装的“垮掉派”。
I got married again almost immediately, after a wild and passionate romance based on the life of D. H. Lawrence and his wife, Rita. Our gods were the same as theirs, the animal life force and art. We worshiped theater, she as an actress, me as a writer. This marriage produced another divine child and still more guilt, for she was married when I met her and left her husband for me, just like Rita did for D. H. And it produced a great deal of jealousy and turbulence.
我几乎立刻又结了婚，那是一段基于D.H.劳伦斯及其妻子丽塔的生活而展开的狂野而热烈的罗曼史。我们的神和他们的一样：动物般的生命力和艺术。我们崇拜戏剧，她是演员，我是作家。这段婚姻生下了另一个神圣的孩子，但也带来了更多的内疚，因为我和她相遇时她已婚，她像丽塔对D.H.那样为了我离开了丈夫。它也带来了大量的嫉妒和动荡。
My dad met his second wife, Maggie, an actress from Germany, in a drama group. He was in the theater program at UCLA and later bragged that he was buddies with Carol Burnett and James Garner, and that Sydney Poitier babysat in exchange for Dad helping him get rid of his bohemian accent. No one in the family believes any of this. The facts are Maggie got pregnant, they got married.
我爸爸是在一个戏剧小组里遇见第二任妻子玛吉的，她是一位来自德国的演员。他在加州大学洛杉矶分校的戏剧系，后来吹嘘自己和卡萝尔·伯内特、詹姆斯·加纳是好友，还说西德尼·波蒂埃曾因为爸爸帮他摆脱波西米亚口音而帮爸爸照看过孩子。家里没一个人相信这些鬼话。事实是玛吉怀孕了，他们就结婚了。
I'm Josie, and I'm from Keith's second marriage. And I was born in 1955.
我是乔西，我是基思第二段婚姻生的。我出生于1955年。
I drove 25 hours from Shelly's house in Eugene to see my half sister, Josie, in Boulder, Colorado, Josie's 45 years old and lives with her son. On our first night together, we're in a condo, looking at a photo album Dad made for her.
我开了25个小时的车，从雪莉在尤金的家来到科罗拉多州博尔德看我的同父异母姐妹乔西。乔西45岁，和儿子住在一起。我们在一起的第一晚，我们在公寓里看着爸爸为她制作的相册。
We lived on Holly Drive in Hollywood Hills, in a little red house. There's this shot that I always remember about the three of us, my mother, the glam actress, with her hair in a bun and very red lipstick, and almost Joan Crawford eyebrows that aren't so great, and my father, who is like the all-American guy. Then I'm in this nice little dress.
我们住在好莱坞山的霍利大道上一座红色小房子里。我总是记得这张我们三个人的照片：我母亲，那个魅力十足的女演员，头发盘成发髻，涂着大红唇，画着类似琼·克劳馥那种不太好看的眉毛，还有我父亲，那个像全美式典型的男人。然后是我，穿着漂亮的小裙子。
He writes underneath it, the family of the '50s, which that is really what this photo is. It's the family of the '50s. However, we weren't the family of the '50s.
他在照片下面写着：50年代的家庭。这确实就是这张照片的含义。这是50年代的家庭。然而，我们根本不是那种50年代的家庭。
My Dad took a lot of pictures. And a lot of them have this quality. They're almost iconic, as if "family of the '50s" was this role he was trying to get the family to play.
爸爸拍了很多照片。很多照片都有这种特质。它们几乎具有标志性，仿佛“50年代的家庭”就是他试图让全家人扮演的角色。
After being scouted in a theater production at UCLA, Dad was cast in a bit part in a Grace Kelly movie, The Bridges at Toko-Ri, and thought he was on his way to a career as a movie actor.
在加州大学洛杉矶分校的戏剧作品中被星探发现后，爸爸在格蕾丝·凯莉的电影《托科里桥的作战》中得到了一个龙套角色，并以为自己即将开启电影演员的职业生涯。
Apparently, he had the chance to work at Paramount. And those were still the days when actors were hired to be contract actors for different studios. And what my mother told me was that-- his ears stick out a little bit, which we all know that they did-- and my mother told me that if he had had his ears pinned back, that they would've accepted him into the studio as one of the contract actors. And my mother just really couldn't understand why he didn't do that. It would've been so easy.
显然，他曾有机会在派拉蒙工作。那时演员仍被雇佣为不同制片厂的合同演员。我母亲告诉我的是——他的耳朵有点招风，我们都知道——母亲说如果他把耳朵修整一下，制片厂就会接受他成为合同演员。我母亲真是不理解他为什么不那么做。那本来很容易的。
And that's kind of like Dad was, you know. He could have been onto something really good, but no, he had this dream. And he had to be a playwright. And that really never went anywhere as well.
爸爸就是那样的人，你知道。他本可以有番大作为，但他有这个梦想。他必须成为一名剧作家。那个梦想也从未实现过。
So he didn't really believe in the Hollywood system. He really wanted to do theater.
所以他不怎么相信好莱坞体系。他真的想搞戏剧。
Yeah, he wanted to do theater. And I don't think he believed in any system. No rules. Don't fence me in. I don't know.
是的，他想搞戏剧。而且我不认为他相信任何体系。没有规则。别想束缚我。我不知道。
Well, we moved to New York when I was about three. He went before us. He went to join a group of men who were playwrights. And he was encouraged by a friend of his. Oh, let's go to New York, and we can become famous playwrights.
嗯，我们大约三岁时搬到了纽约。他先过去的。他去加入了一群剧作家。在他朋友的鼓励下，噢，我们去纽约吧，我们可以成为著名的剧作家。
And Dad was a bit impulsive. And he didn't like the acting scene in Hollywood. So he decided, yeah, let's do it. He goes with his friend. And then about six months later, my mother and I came after him.
爸爸有点冲动。而且他不喜欢好莱坞的表演环境。所以他决定，是的，就这么干。他和朋友一起去了。大约六个月后，我和母亲才去追随他。
In the classic American biographies, there are always these heroic moments, the rebel leaving behind the old life, taking risks, following his or her dream and ending up famous. But of course, most people who tear up their lives and follow their dreams never make it. My dad moved to New York, wrote nothing of value, and had to get a real job in publishing.
在经典的美国传记中，总有这些英雄时刻：叛逆者抛弃旧生活，冒险尝试，追随梦想最终成名。但当然，大多数撕裂生活、追逐梦想的人永远无法成功。我父亲搬到纽约，没写出什么有价值的作品，不得不找了一份出版业的正经工作。
The marriage didn't survive the move either. By the time Josie was five, Keith and Maggie were divorced. But he didn't abandon Josie, as he'd left behind the kids from his first marriage. Maybe he was more mature. Maybe he needed family more. But even after the divorce, he was often a very good dad.
婚姻也没能挺过这次搬家。当乔西五岁时，基思和玛吉离婚了。但他并没有像对待第一次婚姻的孩子那样抛弃乔西。也许他成熟了些。也许他更需要家庭。但即使在离婚后，他通常还是个很好的父亲。
When he chose to be, he was really fun. He played with you. He laughed a lot. He talked to you and made you feel important. He was intense and larger than life, like he was playing the perfect dad.
当他选择做一个好父亲时，他真的很有趣。他陪你玩。他笑得很多。他和你交谈，让你感觉自己很重要。他情绪激烈，仿佛生活在现实之外，就像在扮演完美的父亲。
And with me, he would sometimes sit down. And I would dictate poems to him that I had made up. And he'd type them for me. And so that was a nice little thing that we did as father and daughter.
对我，他有时会坐下来。我编了诗，念给他听，他就帮我打印出来。那是我们父女间一件温馨的小事。
But he was kind of giddy. He was funny. I thought he looked like Dick Van Dyke and acted like Dick Van Dyke, and wished he had been a Dick Van Dyke, this movie star. I think I always wanted him to be a movie star. But yeah, it was like his life was a movie. And at this stage, when I was seven or eight or nine, it was kind of like we were in a musical, singing in the rain and jumping around the streets of New York and making up songs.
但他有点轻浮。他很有趣。我觉得他长得像迪克·范·戴克，演得也像迪克·范·戴克，我真希望他就是迪克·范·戴克，那个电影明星。我想我总是希望他成为电影明星。但是的，感觉他的生活就是一部电影。在那个阶段，当我七岁、八岁或九岁时，感觉就像我们身处音乐剧中，在雨中歌唱，在纽约街头跳跃，编着歌儿。
When did you feel a change come in your family that was pulling him away? Do you remember the time?
你是什么时候感觉到家庭里有了变化，把他从你身边拉走了？你还记得那个时间吗？
Oh, yeah. Well, when he married your mother. And then he started to have a new family with her. And yeah, that was hard for me.
噢，记得。嗯，当他和你母亲结婚时。然后他又和她有了个新家庭。是的，那对我来说很难。
1963 to 1969, literati. My mother, Sally, was Dad's assistant at McGraw-Hill Publishers. She was completely taken with his charm. She told me she came home her first day from work and told her parents that she was going to marry her boss. And within a year, they were married.
1963年至1969年，文人时期。我母亲萨莉是爸爸在麦格劳-希尔出版社的助理。她完全被他的魅力迷住了。她告诉我，第一天上班回到家，她就告诉父母她要嫁给老板。一年之内，他们就结婚了。
The next few years were the happiest I had known since I was a kid. I suppressed my deep yearning to be an artist. And my wife and I devoted ourselves more or less to the good life. We had clothes and money and went out a lot. We had no spiritual life at all, but we didn't  miss it. We were sophisticates.
接下来的几年是我自幼以来最快乐的时光。我压抑了内心成为艺术家的渴望。我和妻子多多少少致力于过上好生活。我们有衣服，有钱，经常出去玩。我们根本没有精神生活，但我们并不觉得缺失。我们是精致的文明人。
According to my mother, Dad used to say that he married her for two reasons, her ass and her family. Dad seemed to think he was moving up in the world, marrying the daughter of a well-known New York editor, Cecil Scott, whose authors include James Michener and Barbara Tuchman. Josie felt like she was losing Dad to another world.
据我母亲说，爸爸曾说他娶她是因为两个原因：她的屁股和她的家庭。爸爸似乎认为通过娶著名纽约编辑塞西尔·斯科特的女儿，他的阶层跃升了，塞西尔的作者包括詹姆斯·米切纳和芭芭拉·塔奇曼。乔西觉得她正因另一个世界而失去爸爸。
And I saw something change in him where I thought he was extremely phony when he'd have talks and smoke cigarettes and drink his scotch with Cecil. Cecil was an editor at McMillan. And his authors, the people he was involved with were bestselling authors. And in the literary world, they were the top people. And so, I think Dad was just so impressed with that and wanted to impress Cecil and let him know-- let Cecil know-- that hey, your daughter isn't marrying a hick from Illinois or Oklahoma. I've got some worth.
我看到他有了某种变化，我觉得当他抽着烟，和塞西尔喝着苏格兰威士忌侃侃而谈时，他极其虚伪。塞西尔是麦克米伦的编辑。他的作者、他交往的人都是畅销书作家。在文学界，他们是顶尖人物。所以我认为爸爸对此印象深刻，想以此给塞西尔留下深刻印象——让塞西尔知道——嘿，你女儿嫁的不是个俄克拉荷马州的乡巴佬。我很有价值。
And I think that's really what he was trying to do was prove something about himself, or reinvent himself. He was always reinventing himself. So here he was going through a stage now where he could come up to Chappaqua and know how to dress and do what the Methodists were doing. And when we'd go up for the weekends, I thought, my god, what is-- this is so not me. This is so not my dad, this whole suburban trip. It was just so strange. I saw Dad playing a role.
我认为他真的是想证明关于他自己的某些东西，或者重塑自我。他总是在重塑自我。所以此时他正在经历一个阶段，可以来到查帕夸，知道怎么穿衣，做那些卫理公会教徒做的事。当我们周末去的时候，我想，天哪，这是什么——这太不是我了。这根本不是我爸爸，这整个郊区生活。这太奇怪了。我看到爸爸在扮演一个角色。
For the record, my mom didn't have any of these pretensions. She was used to this world. She was a painter, an artist in her own right. For the first five years of their marriage, Mom and Dad lived happily in the upper west side of New York City. That's where my older brother, Scott, was born.
声明一下，我妈妈没有这些虚荣心。她习惯了这个世界。她本身就是一名画家、艺术家。他们婚后的头五年，爸妈在纽约上西区过得很幸福。我哥哥斯科特就是在那儿出生的。
1969 to 1972, the ice storm. Right before I was born, my parents decided it was time to move to the suburbs, so they could raise their kids in the stable environment of a nice small town. As it turned out, this was the place our lives fell apart, in a big old house in Katonah, an hour's commute from New York. To find out more about this period, I visited Alan, the youngest child from my father's first marriage. He lived with us in Katonah for over a year.
1969年至1972年，《冰风暴》。在我出生前不久，父母决定搬到郊区，这样他们就可以在稳定的小镇环境中抚养孩子。结果证明，这是我们生活分崩离析的地方，在那栋位于卡托纳的大老宅里，离纽约一个小时车程。为了了解这段时期，我拜访了父亲第一次婚姻中最小的孩子艾伦。他在卡托纳和我们住了一年多。
Now he's in the woods of New Hampshire. He lives like the ex-hippie he is. He enjoys sing-alongs with his guitar, talks freely about sex, makes a living as a computer programmer. Alan was 17 during the year he lived with us. He'd moved out from San Diego to finish high school with his father.
现在他在新罕布什尔州的森林里。他过着典型的过气嬉皮士生活。他喜欢弹着吉他唱歌，谈性很开放，靠做电脑程序员谋生。艾伦和我们住的那一年17岁。他从圣地亚哥搬出来，想和父亲一起读完高中。
It was just great. I thought it was just the most wonderful place to live in the world, because I could smoke and drink and be adult and sophisticated and all these things. They had some really neat friends. They would have these parties. And people would sit around and talk about all kinds of [BLEEP], you know.
这太棒了。我觉得那是世界上最美妙的居住地，因为我可以抽烟、喝酒、表现得成熟老练，做所有那些事。他们有一些很棒的朋友。他们会开派对。人们坐在一起谈论各种[消音]，你知道的。
For a couple of years in Katonah, all of my dad's kids intersected at various times. Besides Alan, Becky and Shelly, also from the first marriage, lived there briefly after high school. And Josie, from the second marriage, came up from the city to visit on weekends.
在卡托纳的那几年，我爸爸所有的孩子在不同时期有过交集。除了艾伦，第一次婚姻中的贝基和雪莉高中毕业后也曾在那儿短暂停留。而来自第二次婚姻的乔西，周末也会从城里过来探望。
But shortly after moving to Katonah, Dad went through his next transformation, a radical left turn away from the suburban stodginess he had chosen. The year was 1969. Here's how my dad described it.
但搬到卡托纳后不久，爸爸经历了下一次蜕变，彻底背离了他最初选择的郊区刻板生活。那一年是1969年。我爸爸是这样描述的。
By this time, I was 40 pounds overweight, had regular three-martini lunches, and truth to tell, I was officious. There were riots in the streets. The kids had long hair and wore overalls. And they looked at me as if I was the enemy.
到这个时候，我超重40磅，午餐习惯喝三杯马丁尼，说实话，我很自以为是。街上发生了骚乱。孩子们留长发，穿工装裤。他们看着我，仿佛我是敌人。
When I got there, he made it very clear to me that he was not going to be my father. He was going to be my buddy. He never asked me, where are you going, or how long are you going to be, or where have you been and what were you doing and that sort of thing. If he asked me anything, and I told him, and it was anything the least bit racy or off-beat or anything like that, he would just think that was really great. And the more I did, the more great he thought it was.
当我到那儿时，他向我明确表示他不会做我的父亲。他要做我的哥们儿。他从不问我：你要去哪，要待多久，你去哪儿了，做了什么，诸如此类。如果他问我什么，我告诉他，即使那稍微有点大胆或前卫，他也会觉得那太棒了。我做得越多，他越觉得棒。
That was a very tumultuous time, not because Alan was there, really, but because of all the changes Dad was going through. And he was beginning to get into drugs.
那是一段非常动荡的时期，不是因为艾伦在那儿，而是因为爸爸正在经历的所有变化。他开始接触毒品。
This is Josie.
这是乔西。
Meaning he was smoking marijuana. And I think they were both taking LSD and also mescaline. So all of this was going on where Alan was kind of involved.
意思是他在吸大麻。我认为他们都在用LSD，还有墨斯卡林。所以所有这些事情都在进行，艾伦也被卷进去了。
And I was even involved. I'd go up there on every other week and sometimes smoke with them at a very young age. And it's absolutely incredible to me now that I did this. And all these people coming in and out of that house.
甚至连我也卷进去了。我每隔一周就会去那儿，有时还在很小的年纪就和他们一起吸食。现在想起来真是不可思议。而且还有那么多人进进出出那所房子。
In an era where adults were trying to be teenagers, Dad quit his job and considered himself the guru to the resident teenagers, Alan and his girlfriend, Stephanie. Here's Alan again.
在一个成年人试图装作青少年的时代，爸爸辞去了工作，自认为是住在那儿的青少年——艾伦和他女友斯蒂芬妮的导师。再听听艾伦说的。
I was still smoking and doing acid and whatnot, and so was he. And he was finding that he was really enjoying this kind of really liberated lifestyle. I think he felt that I was outdoing him somehow in terms of my liberatedness, and he was in competition with me to see who could be the wildest, or something. In fact, he kind of came down to my level a lot.
我还在吸烟、吸毒什么的，他也一样。他发现自己真的很享受这种极其解放的生活方式。我想他觉得我在解放程度上超过了他，他在和我比赛，看谁更疯狂。事实上，他经常降级到我的水平。
I don't know if I ever told you this, but he came on to Stephanie one time. He offered to take her home when I was too stoned or drunk or something like that, and she needed to get home. And he drove her home. And he attacked her on the way home. He pulled over, started sticking his tongue down her throat and everything.
我不知道我有没有告诉过你，他有一次勾引了斯蒂芬妮。在我喝得太醉或被熏得太晕时，他主动提出送她回家，因为她需要回去。他在送她回家的路上袭击了她。他把车停在路边，把舌头伸进她喉咙里，做了那一切。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
My girlfriend, you know? A 17, 18-year-old girl. And that really pissed me off. It certainly pissed her off. And she didn't want anything to do with our family after that. And I was really love with her. I was so angry at him about that.
我女朋友，你知道吗？一个17、18岁的女孩。那真的很让我火大。她当然也气坏了。在那之后，她不想和我们家有任何瓜葛。我真的很爱她。为此我对他非常愤怒。
Did you confront him?
你和他当面对质了吗？
No.
没有。
You didn't?
没对质？
No. I couldn't. I was so frightened of him. I had seen his anger against Sally. By that time, he was starting, I think, to feel like Sally was dragging him down, or something, or kind of a millstone around his neck in terms of his liberatedness, or something like that. And he would just blow off at a drop of a hat at that point.
没有。我不敢。我太怕他了。我见识过他对萨莉的愤怒。那时我感觉他已经开始认为萨莉在拖他后腿，或者在某种程度上成为他解放之路上的绊脚石。那时候他随时都会爆发。
I remember distinctly sitting down in that little dining room in Katonah there one morning. And for some reason, he didn't like the way she cooked the eggs or something. And something she said set him off.
我清楚地记得那天早上坐在卡托纳的那个小餐厅里。因为某些原因，他不喜欢她炒鸡蛋的方式或类似的事情。她说的某句话让他爆发了。
And he just threw his plate against the wall. And then he threw the table against the other wall and just started ripping up the dining room, taking pictures off the walls and smashing them over chairs, and smashing chairs into splinters. And Sally was just screaming and cowering in the corner of the room.
他把盘子摔在墙上。接着把桌子撞到另一面墙上，开始砸餐厅，把墙上的画摘下来砸在椅子上，把椅子砸成碎片。萨莉在房间角落里尖叫缩成一团。
And I've never been so petrified in all my life as I was during that scene. And then an hour later, it was over. It was like we were all supposed to pretend like nothing had happened.
那一幕是我人生中最恐惧的一次。一个小时后，一切都结束了。好像我们都得假装什么都没发生过。
Oh, I don't remember. Just whenever I was rebellious, or maybe I mouthed off to him, he'd slap me around and really throw me across the room.
噢，我不记得了。只是每当我叛逆时，或者顶嘴了，他就会扇我耳光，把我扔过房间去。
Here's Josie again.
这是乔西。
And really, that was quite a distance. I was a pretty skinny kid. But he would just unleash his wrath on me.
那距离真的很远。我当时是个瘦巴巴的孩子。但他就会把怒火倾泻在我身上。
But I do remember one time that I did prevent him from really-- I knew that I was going to be harmed terribly because I stood up for myself. And what I did was I screamed "help" for the police. And the police came. A next-door neighbor came.
但我确实记得有一次我阻止了他……我知道我会受到严重伤害，因为我站出来维护自己。我尖叫着“警察，救命”。警察来了。邻居也来了。
And then it continued. And it just continued. It didn't stop.
之后这一切还在继续。一直在继续。没有停止。
This is my brother, Scott. He was probably four years old at this time.
这是我哥哥，斯科特。他当时可能才四岁。
One of my earliest memories in Katonah is waking up and hearing screaming downstairs, and seeing Dad being manhandled by police downstairs, as I'm sitting on the staircase with Mom, and she's holding me. And he apparently had just thrown Josie against a window. And some neighbor saw it and came over and beat the [BLEEP] out of Dad. And he was bleeding, and the police were there trying to calm him down. And it seemed to me like they were nearly locking him up.
我在卡托纳最早的记忆之一是醒来听到楼下的尖叫声，看到爸爸在楼下被警察粗暴对待，我坐在楼梯上，妈妈抱着我。显然他刚才把乔西撞到了窗户上。邻居看见了，过来把爸爸狠狠打了一顿。他流血了，警察在那里试图平息他的情绪。看来他们差点就把他关起来了。
During that time of this fight with the neighbor, the blood was rushing down and was staining his white suit. And that was just such an image, to see Dad. Dad was getting hit. The police were coming. And maybe I did feel a little empowered. Who knew that word and that term?
在那场和邻居的打斗中，血流了下来，弄脏了他的白西装。看到爸爸的那一幕真是……爸爸挨了打。警察来了。也许我确实感到了一点点权力感。谁知道那个词和那个概念呢？
And then when I walked into the bathroom, seeing him wash his white clothing to get the stain out. And he looked up at me, and he said, "I don't want to know you. And I don't want to have anything to do with you. And you're on the next train." And that was that.
当我走进浴室，看到他洗那套白衣服想去掉污渍。他抬起头看着我，说：“我不想认识你。我不想和你扯上任何关系。你坐下一班火车走人。”就这样。
I think that he would get overwhelmed by his emotions, that somehow he felt that he was his emotions. And when he had an emotion, he had to feel it fully, even if it meant smashing his foot through a door or beating up someone, like his wife. And he almost felt that to censor that was to censor his own creativity.
我认为他会被情绪淹没，以至于他觉得他就是他的情绪本身。当他产生情绪时，他必须彻底释放，即使这意味着一脚踹烂一扇门或者打伤别人，比如他的妻子。他甚至认为审查这些情绪就是在审查他自己的创造力。
And I think that he was of a generation that might have glamorized that, to a certain extent. I think that the artists of his generation that he admired, like Henry Miller or Jackson Pollock, people that, in many ways, Dad emulated these types. And I think that these are tremendously successful individuals, but they also lived life on the edge. And I think there was sort of a cult of that, of an appeal to that, that I think Dad was susceptible to.
我认为他那一代人可能在某种程度上美化了这一点。他仰慕的那些同代艺术家，像亨利·米勒或杰克逊·波洛克，在很多方面，爸爸都在效仿这类人。我认为这些人是非常成功的人士，但他们也在边缘生活。我认为这是一种崇拜，一种吸引力，爸爸很容易受到这种影响。
In a sense, who else would embody so many different cultural trends over the course of 40 years, other than someone who gives in to all his emotions? That same quality that made him so charismatic and engaging, that made him such a great dad sometimes, also made him a terror.
从某种意义上说，除了一个任由情绪发泄的人，还有谁会在40年里体现出如此多的文化潮流？正是那种使他极具魅力、有时成为好父亲的特质，也使他成了一个恐怖分子。
I was alive during the mayhem in Katonah, but it all happened before I was three years old. So I don't remember any of it. But to Josie, I was very much a part of the drama.
卡托纳的骚乱发生时我还活着，但那发生在我三岁之前。所以我什么都不记得了。但在乔西看来，我是那场闹剧的一部分。
Oh, I felt ashamed because there were some bad things going on. For instance, if your parents had come home from a party or something, or they were just smoking marijuana and listening to music and involved in their own lives, or whatever, their discussions. And I'd be going upstairs and I'd be checking on you. Or I'd hear you crying, and I'd hear you crying and crying and crying, and no would come to see you. And there you'd be in the crib.
噢，我感到羞愧，因为当时发生了一些糟糕的事情。例如，如果你父母刚从派对回来，或者他们只是在吸大麻、听音乐、沉浸在自己的生活中，或者无论什么谈话中。我上楼去查看你们。或者我听到你在哭，一直哭一直哭，没有人来管你。你就那样呆在摇篮里。
I guess I was ashamed because I felt like I turned my back on you guys, on you little kids. And I came less and less to Katonah. And when I had a big blow-up with Dad, I felt like I never saw you again. And I felt like I didn't want to see you again. Because it conjured up so many horrible images.
我想我感到羞愧是因为我觉得我背弃了你们，背弃了你们这些小孩。我来卡托纳的次数越来越少。当我跟爸爸大吵一架后，我觉得我再也没见过你。而且我觉得我不想再见到你了。因为它引发了太多可怕的记忆。
This was completely new to me. When I sat down to interview Josie, we barely knew each other. I'd always heard the stories about this crazy period when my dad actually lived in the house I grew up in. But I never thought of myself as a part of it. And when Josie first mentioned it, I brushed it off.
这对我是全新的发现。当我坐下来采访乔西时，我们几乎不认识彼此。我总能听到关于爸爸住在我长大的那栋房子里的疯狂时期的故事。但我从没想过自己也是那儿的一部分。乔西第一次提到时，我没当回事。
Then one afternoon, after we went for a hike in the mountains, she came into my room, visibly upset. She started to cry for me and Scott. She felt so guilty that we were so neglected, and for abandoning us.
那天下午，我们在山里徒步旅行后，她走进我的房间，神情不安。她开始为我和斯科特哭泣。她为我们被忽视以及她抛弃我们而感到内疚。
Now I heard her, but I felt like she was talking to the wrong person. I wasn't hurt by that stuff, I said. That wasn't me. It was just a baby I don't relate with. And I pointed out that she was just a kid herself. She had nothing to be guilty about.
现在我听到了，但我感觉她找错人了。我说，我没受那些事的影响。那不是我。那只是个我不记得的婴儿。我指出她自己当时也只是个孩子。她没理由感到内疚。
But it shook me. I guess I'd always thought that while my dad was running around being crazy, my mom was crouched in the corner with me safely tucked under her arm. It didn't occur to me that I was caught up in all of the chaos.
但这震撼了我。我想我一直以为当爸爸在外面疯狂时，妈妈正蹲在角落里安全地抱着我。我没想到我也身处那种混乱之中。
I was starting to realize that the story I was trying to tell couldn't be the same one I had started out to do. I was feeling differently about Dad. I was beginning to have a hard time seeing anything noble about his pursuit of his dreams.
我开始意识到，我想要讲述的故事不可能是我最初打算讲的那个了。我对爸爸的感觉变了。我开始很难看到他追求梦想有什么高尚之处。
1972 to 1978, the time of Bacchus and Batman.
1972年至1978年，酒神与蝙蝠侠时代。
The odd thing is, I believed at the time I was acting in the highest morality. It was basically the morality declared by Abbie Hoffman, the yippie leader, in his book, Steal This Book. The idea was, the system is corrupt beyond salvaging.
奇怪的是，当时我认为我是在践行最高的道德。这基本上是雅皮士领袖艾比·霍夫曼在他的书《窃取此书》中宣布的道德。其理念是：体制腐败不堪，无药可救。
Tear everything down. Rip everything off. You are a law unto yourself. To thine own self be true.
推倒一切。掠夺一切。你自己就是自己的法律。忠于自我。
After my parents' divorce, Dad was still doing a lot of drugs, incapable of holding onto a job or a girlfriend. He was working as a professional actor, which meant he was mostly broke. He was on The Guiding Light for a couple of years, playing an evil Texas lawyer named Raymond Schafer. When we were out with him, women would stop him on the street and ask him for his autograph. We thought that was pretty cool.
父母离婚后，爸爸仍在使用大量毒品，无法保住工作或女友。他作为职业演员工作，这意味着他大部分时间都很拮据。他在《指引之光》里演了几年戏，扮演一个叫雷蒙德·谢弗的邪恶德州律师。当我们和他出去时，女人们会在街上拦住他要签名。我们觉得这挺酷的。
Batman.
蝙蝠侠。
Dick, what's wrong?
迪克，怎么了？
Not Dick, not now. Time for Robin and Batman.
不是迪克，现在不行。蝙蝠侠和罗宾的时间到了。
No?
不？
Dad wrote and acted the part of Batman on a series of records about the Caped Crusader. This one's called If Music Be the Food of Death. To me and my brother, he was a superhero. I was seven years old.
爸爸在关于这位蒙面侠的一系列唱片里编写并扮演了蝙蝠侠。这张唱片叫《如果音乐是死亡的食物》。对于我和哥哥来说，他是超级英雄。我当时七岁。
We have to pull the lever with a letter that answers the riddle. Hmm. A letter like an escape.
我们必须拉动带有 riddle 谜底字母的杠杆。嗯。一个像逃生一样的字母。
When we saw him on the weekends, he was at his best, attentive and fun.
周末见到他时，他是最好的，专注而有趣。
Good, Robin, good. What's the other one?
好，罗宾，很好。另一个是什么？
Why is a speeding train like a citizen of Moscow?
为什么一列疾驰的火车像莫斯科公民？
Hmm, of course, of course.
嗯，当然，当然。
What is it?
是什么？
They're both rushin'.
他们都在赶时间（Rushin' / Russian）。
True to form, Dad's life was just about to turn upside down once again.
一如既往，爸爸的生活又一次要天翻地覆了。
Coming up, one child found, one child lost. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个孩子找到了，一个孩子丢了。一分钟后，我们的节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. In a sense, there are lots of families like the Aldriches. A parent leaves, remarries, makes a new life. And the kids in the first marriage are left to make sense of it somehow.
这是《美国生活》。从某种意义上说，有很多像奥尔德里奇这样的家庭。父母离开，再婚，开始新生活。第一段婚姻里的孩子只能以某种方式试着去理解。
The Aldriches are just an extreme case. Dad left five different families. Nine kids were left struggling what to make of it, and what to make of each other. Gillian's story continues.
奥尔德里奇家只是一个极端案例。爸爸留下了五个不同的家庭。九个孩子在挣扎，不知如何面对这一切，不知如何面对彼此。吉莉安的故事继续。
Harry was the one sibling who didn't come to Dad's funeral. Shelly was the only one of us who had ever met him. No one had any idea where he was.
哈里是唯一没有来参加爸爸葬礼的兄弟。雪莉是我们中唯一见过他的人。没人知道他在哪。
I finally found him on the internet. It turns out that he lives in New York, where I live. I didn't know if he'd want anything to do with the family, because my dad practically disowned him. But he was as excited to meet as I was.
我终于在网上找到了他。原来他住在纽约，我也住在那儿。我不知道他是否想和这个家庭有任何牵连，因为我爸爸几乎和他断绝了关系。但他和我一样兴奋地想见面。
Harry?
哈里？
Yes.
是的。
Hi.
你好。
Hi. What's up?
你好。怎么了？
I'm sorry to do this.
抱歉打扰了。
That's OK.
没关系。
How are you?
你好吗？
Good.
很好。
Good to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
We were both pretty nervous.
我们俩当时都很紧张。
So you're my brother. So what do you think? Do we look alike?
所以你是我的弟弟。你怎么看？我们长得像吗？
I think it'll grow on me. But yeah.
我觉得我会习惯的。但确实。
You do? Do you see anything?
真的吗？你看到什么相似之处了吗？
As far as I'm concerned, there's a huge family resemblance. He has exactly the same low hairline and stick-out ears my dad had. He looks a lot like my dad, actually.
就我而言，有着巨大的家庭特征。他有着和我爸爸完全一样低的额头线条和招风耳。事实上，他看起来很像我爸爸。
Harry's 22 years old. He's smart and funny. We were instantly comfortable with each other.
哈里22岁。他聪明有趣。我们瞬间就感到非常融洽。
Harry was born during the mid '70s, in the midst of Dad's unstable life in New York. Dad dated Harry's mom for a few months. She got pregnant. Dad rejected her.
哈里出生在70年代中期，正值爸爸在纽约不稳定的生活期间。爸爸和哈里的母亲约会了几个月。她怀孕了。爸爸拒绝了她。
She moved to a commune in Tennessee called The Farm, where Harry grew up. Dad only saw Harry a handful of times. And Harry's few memories of Dad take place mostly 10 or 15 years after he was born.
她搬到了田纳西州一个叫“农场”的公社，哈里在那里长大。爸爸只见过哈里屈指可数的几次。哈里仅有的那点关于爸爸的记忆，大多发生在他出生10或15年后。
I guess I have three or four memories, I think it might have been over the course of two trips. This was when he lived in a condo in southern California. I don't think he was attached at the time. He was living such a early '90s microwave life is the only way to put it.
我想我有三四个记忆，可能是在两次旅行中。那是他住在南加州公寓的时候。我不认为他当时有对象。他过着那种极度90年代初的“微波炉生活”，这是我唯一能形容的方式。
It was one of the pop-up condominium strips in southern California, which are just like wildfire across southern California. I would go there, and we'd go to the grocery store and buy three frozen pizzas and come back and microwave them. He lived this total microwave existence. And everything about his life seemed like just pop in, pop out kind of thing.
那是南加州那种像野火一样蔓延的快速建成的公寓群之一。我过去那儿，我们会去杂货店买三个冷冻披萨，然后回来放进微波炉。他过着一种完全微波炉式的存在。他生活中一切似乎都是那种即插即用、即兴抛弃的类型。
So we're at this apartment. And I guess I was vacuuming with a little hand-vac. And he was still sort of in the process of moving into his place. And I bumped a box that a lamp was on, and the lamp fell. And it didn't work.
我们在那间公寓里。我想我当时在用一个小手持吸尘器吸尘。他还在往那个地方搬东西。我撞到了一个放灯的箱子，灯掉下来了。它不亮了。
And so I just got paranoid. I was like, oh my gosh, I think I broke this lamp. And so I didn't want to not tell him. The smart thing to do maybe would have been to not tell him. But my conscience forced me to go in there.
我变得很偏执。我想，天哪，我想我把这盏灯弄坏了。我不想隐瞒。明智的做法也许是别告诉他。但良心强迫我进去。
And I said, I think I broke the lamp. It's not working. And he went in there. And he tried to turn it on, and it didn't work.
我说，我想我把灯弄坏了。它不亮了。他走进去。他试着打开，它没亮。
And he just exploded. He just freaked out. He just started tearing apart his office. He dropped the lamp on the ground, and he was just storming and standing there, screaming at me and throwing things on the ground, spilling his papers all over the place, sweeping things, just like a maniac.
他立刻爆发了。他完全疯了。他开始拆他的办公室。他把灯扔在地上，咆哮着站在那里，对我大喊大叫，把东西扔在地上，把文件撒得到处都是，像个疯子一样挥舞东西。
And he finally just calmed down. And then he took the lamp. And he went, and he checked the bulb. And the bulb had broken. And he changed the bulb, and the lamp worked.
他终于冷静下来。然后他拿起灯。他去检查了灯泡。原来是灯泡坏了。他换了个灯泡，灯亮了。
And so then we just cleaned up the room. And he was apologetic. And he's like, man, why did I do this. And I'm thinking, even if this lamp had been broken, you caused 10 times more trouble flipping out about it. Obviously, I guess he was just struggling with a lot of things. I don't think it had to do with the lamp at all.
于是我们清理了房间。他表示了歉意。他说，伙计，我为什么要这么做。我在想，即使这盏灯坏了，你为了这事大发雷霆造成的麻烦也是它的十倍。很显然，我想他当时正和很多事情作斗争。我不认为这和灯有什么关系。
On another trip, Harry says Dad was reading the newspaper about the Pan Am flight that went down over Lockerbie, Scotland. Never one to hold anything back, Dad started crying about the victims.
在另一次旅行中，哈里说爸爸在看报纸上关于泛美航空在苏格兰洛克比坠毁的新闻。爸爸从来不是那种会掩饰的人，他开始为受害者哭泣。
And I remember thinking, what a tender thing. This guy is really real. He's compassionate. He's crying for all these people. And I remember almost feeling bad, like gee, why am I not more broken up about this, and wanting to feel more upset about it.
记得当时我觉得：多么温柔。这家伙真的很真实。他很有同情心。他在为所有这些人哭泣。我记得几乎感到难过，像是“天哪，为什么我没有为这事更伤心一点”，并且想要感觉到更多的不安。
But then he went right out of being upset about that to just laying straight into me about me, about existing period. He was like, I don't want you up here. Your mom is just sticking you in my life. I didn't ask for you to come visit.
但接下来，他立刻就不再为此感到难过了，转而开始直接责难我，责难我这个人，责难我的存在。他说：“我不希望你待在这里。你妈只是把你硬塞进我的生活。我没叫你来探望我。”
And then he starts going into all these things about I've never even wanted you. You were just a manipulation that your mom used to try and get to me. And he was just railing at me. And I remember feeling so, so worthless and so insecure and so unhappy, and just scared and depressed.
然后他开始列举所有那些事，说他从未想要我。我只是你妈试图利用我而使用的工具。他对我咆哮。记得当时我感到如此、如此一无是处，如此不安，如此不开心，只感到害怕和沮丧。
I remember it was around that time when I was like-- it may have been around that time. But it was experiences like that that made me think, I don't know what it would have been like to have actually ever spent any period of my life being raised by this person. I could not imagine what it would be like to have to go home from school and know that he was going to be there. And I thought, I could not have handled it. I would have broken. I would have absolutely broken.
我记得那是大约在那个时候……经历过这种事让我想到，我不知道如果有机会让我被这个人抚养，哪怕是一段时间，会是什么样。我无法想象回家后得知他在那儿是什么感觉。我想，我无法承受。我会崩溃的。我会彻底崩溃的。
And I remember feeling so grateful, so grateful, that I had not been raised by him at all. Because I never felt let down that Keith had not raised me at all, that he had not been there for me. The honest truth of the way I felt was why is he even coming along now and making it harder.
我记得我感到如此感激，如此感激，我竟然完全没被他抚养大。因为我从未感到基思没有养育我而感到失落，因为他本就不该出现在我的生活中。我内心最诚实的感受是：为什么他现在还要跑出来把生活搞得更糟？
Growing up the furthest from Dad, having the least contact with him of any of us, Harry's also the least conflicted of all the siblings. Me, I'm not nearly so settled.
作为所有兄弟姐妹中与爸爸距离最远、联系最少的人，哈里也是我们中最不纠结的。至于我，我可没那么心安。
1979 to 1988, reborn again. Around the time that Ronald Reagan took office, and the Moral Majority began to hold sway around the country, my father became a Christian.
1979年至1988年，重生。罗纳德·里根入主白宫、全国各地“道德多数派”开始得势前后，我父亲成了基督徒。
It was beginning to appear that my life was going to amount to nothing, a big fat zero. By now, I had trampled roughshod over the feelings and hearts of scores of people who loved me-- family, friends, children, lovers, associates-- all on the altar of my artistry. My self-contempt made me meaner than ever, and I was usually stoned or a little smashed.
生活开始看起来我终将一事无成，归于零。到那时，我已经为了艺术的祭坛，狠狠践踏了无数爱我的人的心——家人、朋友、孩子、爱人、同事。对自我的蔑视使我变得比以往任何时候都更卑劣，而且我通常处于吸毒或醉酒的状态。
In the late '70s, shortly after Harry was born, one of my dad's girlfriends began dragging him to meetings at an evangelical church.
70年代末，哈里出生后不久，爸爸的一个女朋友开始拖着他去参加一个福音教会的聚会。
My mind, which had been closed for so many years, was beginning to open. The hardness of my heart began to melt. I teetered on the brink of believing. I longed so to believe.
我的头脑，已经关闭了多年，开始打开。我那颗坚硬的心开始融化。我在信仰的边缘摇摇欲坠。我是如此渴望去相信。
My father was saved, born again. He moved to California and briefly lived his lifelong dream of doing his own theater. He traveled around southern California, performing his Christian plays.
我父亲得救了，重生了。他搬到加州，短暂实现了他一生的梦想：创作自己的戏剧。他在南加州四处巡演他的基督教戏剧。
At the end of each performance, Dad would stand up and preach, calling people up front to be saved, laying his hands on the repentant. Scott started thinking Dad was a weirdo and a fake. He could see that Dad was as aggressive and self-obsessed as he'd ever been, but now it was all in the service of Jesus.
每场表演结束后，爸爸都会站起来传道，呼召人们到台前得救，并为悔改者按手祷告。斯科特开始觉得爸爸是个怪胎和骗子。他看出爸爸和以前一样极具攻击性且自私自利，但现在这一切都是为了耶稣。
We were driving out to the desert, and Dad was speaking in tongues. And I was in the front seat. You were in the back. We were on our way to Palm Springs. And Dad was speaking in tongues. And it sounded like, "Oh shalakh halem alakh hulum alakh haleng." Those were the kind of sounds it sounded like. And you and I used to look at each other like, "what the hell is he doing?"
我们开车去沙漠，爸爸在说方言。我坐在前座。你在后座。我们在去棕榈泉的路上。爸爸在说方言。听起来像：“Oh shalakh halem alakh hulum alakh haleng。”听起来就是那种声音。你和我以前常互相对视，心想：“他在搞什么鬼？”
And I remember I said, "So Dad, what is that chanting you're doing?" And I said, "Is that some ancient Hebrew? Are you praying?" And he said, "Well, it's interesting you ask that, because I don't know what it is. It could be some ancient, dead tongue. But," he said, "I received the Holy Spirit. And when you receive the Holy Spirit, the Holy Spirit speaks through you."
我记得我说：“所以爸爸，你念的那些咒语是什么？”我说：“那是古希伯来语吗？你在祈祷吗？”他说：“很高兴你这么问，因为我不知道那是什么。那可能是某种古老的、死亡的语言。但是，”他说，“我领受了圣灵。当你领受圣灵时，圣灵通过你说话。”
And I said, "Wow, that's very interesting." And he asked if I would like to speak in tongues. And I said, "Uh, well, all right, I guess," totally worried.
我说：“哇，真有意思。”他问我是否也想说方言。我说：“呃，好吧，我想可以，”心里非常担心。
And then he put his hands in my head, and he started speaking in tongues. And he said, "Heavenly father, let the Holy Spirit come through Scott," and everything, and did this whole prayer. And then he said, OK. This was while he was driving too. We were on the interstate in the desert.
然后他把手按在我头上，开始说方言。他说：“天父，让圣灵穿过斯科特，”诸如此类，做了整个祈祷。然后他说，好吧。他当时还在开车。我们在沙漠的州际公路上。
And then he said, "OK, Scott. I want you to speak in tongues." And I was totally self-conscious. And I looked at you. You were just absolutely cracking up silently. And I kept hemming and hawing. He said, "Go ahead. Don't be afraid."
然后他说：“好吧，斯科特。我想让你说方言。”我完全感到自我意识过剩。我看着你。你在后座正憋笑憋得要死。我一直支支吾吾。他说：“继续。别害怕。”
And then I started to speak this language that you and I had made up when we were little kids, like "Obaca lucca shula lucca la." I just made up this language. And you were practically dying in the backseat. And he was just supporting me, like "Oh, that's good, yeah. Keep going. Keep going."
然后我开始说那种我和你在小时候编造的语言，像“Obaca lucca shula lucca la”。我就随口编了这种语言。你在后座简直快笑死了。而他就在那儿支持我：“噢，很好，是的。继续。继续。”
And then we went to visit Grandpa Aldrich. And then he started doing it again with Grandpa Aldrich. And it wasn't any funny anymore.
后来我们去拜访奥尔德里奇爷爷。然后他又开始和爷爷做同样的事。这就一点也不好笑了。
And then Grandpa Aldrich, after he was so afraid, he went to the bathroom in his pants. And we had to deal with it. And Dad just got furious. And I remember just thinking, oh, this poor old man.
爷爷当时很害怕，居然直接吓得拉裤子里了。我们不得不去处理。爸爸变得勃然大怒。我记得当时心想：噢，这个可怜的老人。
At some point, most of my brothers and sisters went through a phase of being Dad's favorite. And then they'd see through him, or he'd turn on them. There was always a confrontation. And it ended. My father's two youngest children, Sarah and Grace, never confronted him like this when he was alive. They were too little. So they're stuck trying to figure out what to make of him now, five years after his death.
在某个阶段，我大多数兄弟姐妹都经历过作为爸爸“最爱”的阶段。然后他们会看穿他，或者他会反目。总会发生冲突。然后结束。我父亲两个最小的孩子，萨拉和格蕾丝，在爸爸活着时从未这样跟他对质过。她们太小了。所以她们现在在去世五年后，还在努力弄明白该拿他怎么办。
I just saw him as two different people. There  was the guy who beat my mom, but then there's the guy who spreads the word. I don't know. It seems so typical. It just seems so-- that's all I know. That's all I've ever known, and that's all I know as a father kind of thing.
我只是把他看作两个不同的人。一个是殴打我妈妈的人，但另一个是传播福音的人。我不知道。这看起来太典型了。这看起来……那就是我所知道的全部。这就是我所知道的作为父亲的一切。
Sarah's Dad's second-youngest. She just turned 18. They're from his marriage to Mary in the 1980s. They grew up mostly in Colorado. Sarah was just a baby when I lived with Dad. And just like Josie felt guilty for abandoning me as a baby, I've always had a nagging guilt for leaving Sarah and Grace behind.
萨拉是爸爸最小的女儿之一。她刚满18岁。她们是他和玛丽在80年代婚姻生的。她们大多在科罗拉多长大。我住在那儿时，萨拉还是个婴儿。就像乔西因为抛弃我这个婴儿而感到内疚，我也一直为留下萨拉和格蕾丝而感到某种萦绕心头的内疚。
I remember loving Daddy a lot. And that's because I never really saw the side that everyone seems to hate about him. He always loved me a lot. And he always told me he did. I was Daddy's girl.
我记得很爱爸爸。那是因为我从未真正见过每个人似乎都讨厌他的那一面。他一直很爱我。他总是告诉我他很爱我。我是爸爸的小棉袄。
It made so much sense for Sarah to be conflicted about that. I saw so much of me in her. I had also been Daddy's girl. And I remember the weekend I felt it transferred to her, one weekend after I'd refused to see my father for a long time, and had clearly asserted my independence from him. In that weekend Dad put all of his emotional, I'd say manipulative, energy into her.
萨拉对这一点感到矛盾是很有道理的。我在她身上看到了很多我的影子。我也曾是爸爸的小棉袄。我记得那种情感转移到她身上的周末，那时我已经很久拒绝见父亲，并清楚地向他表明了我的独立。那个周末，爸爸把他所有的情感——我会说是操纵性的能量——都投入到了她身上。
I remember being in Virginia with you and Dad. Scott and I came down to visit for a weekend and you were up visiting also. Do you remember that?
我记得和你还有爸爸在弗吉尼亚。斯科特和我下去探望了一个周末，你也去探望了。你记得吗？
Yeah, I do remember that.
是啊，我记得。
I remember that you were the most beautiful little girl. And you were just starting to gain a little bit of weight, not a lot, but a little. And we were going out to eat. And Dad kept giving you all this really bad food.
我记得你当时是个最漂亮的小女孩。你刚开始有点变胖，不多，但有一点。我们出去吃饭。爸爸一直给你喂各种很不健康的食物。
And I remember you saying to him, "Daddy, I'm not supposed to eat that. I'm supposed to be on a diet." And he said to you, "Sarah, I love you. And anyone who tells you that you can't eat whatever you want doesn't love you. I think you should eat absolutely anything you want. In fact, tell me what you want, and I'll let you have it." Do you remember that?
我记得你对他说：“爸爸，我不应该吃这个。我应该减肥。”他对你说：“萨拉，我爱你。任何告诉你不能吃你想吃的东西的人，那都不爱你。我认为你绝对应该吃任何你想吃的东西。事实上，告诉我你想要什么，我给你买。”你记得吗？
I don't remember that. I do remember my mom telling me I looked really heavy when I came back, though.
我不记得了。不过我记得我妈妈说我回来时看起来真的很重。
I got the distinct feeling that he wanted you to eat as much as you could eat.
我有一种强烈的预感，他希望你吃得越多越好。
Why? Just so I would love him more or respect him more? I don't know. It took me forever to lose that weight.
为什么？只是为了让我更爱他或更尊敬他吗？我不知道。我花了整整一生才减掉那些体重。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was a fat kid. God, middle school was a pain in the ass.
我是个胖孩子。天哪，中学时代真是痛苦。
I think, and I'm just conjecturing here, and I could be wrong. But I think that he also said to me on that trip, "Sarah's going to be the kid that stays with me. Everyone else has left me. But Sarah's still loyal. She's going to stay with me." And that, combined with his comment about you eating as much as you want, really made me think he was trying to get you to stay with him.
我想，我只是在推测，我可能错了。但我认为在那次旅行中他还对我说：“萨拉会是那个留在我身边的孩子。其他人全离开了我。但萨拉依然忠诚。她会陪着我。”那句话，加上他关于让你随心所欲吃东西的评论，真让我觉得他在试图让你留在他身边。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
While my older brothers and sisters have gone farther in working out their feelings about my father, and in the process have distanced themselves or partially rejected him, Sarah simply can't, not yet anyway.
当我的哥哥姐姐们在理清对父亲的感觉方面走得更远，并在此过程中疏远或部分拒绝他时，萨拉根本做不到，至少现在还不能。
And one thing I remember about my dad is he was taking pictures of me one day. And I still have the pictures. And I look at them now. I had a bad perm, my bad glasses. And it was a time I was getting really hefty. And I was wearing sweats.
我记得爸爸的一件事是，有一天他给我拍照。我还有那些照片。我现在看着它们。我烫了个糟糕的发型，戴着糟糕的眼镜。那是我开始变得真的很壮实的时候。我穿着运动衫。
But I remember specifically when he was taking these pictures. And he was like, "You're an extremely beautiful girl, Sarah." He's like, "You could grow up and take pictures like this for a living," and stuff like that. And no one else said that about me at that time. No one else said that to me.
但我记得他拍这些照片时的情景。他说：“你是个非常漂亮的孩子，萨拉。”他说，“你长大后可以靠拍这样的照片为生，”之类的。那时没别人这么说过我。没别人这么对我说。
It apparently meant a lot to me, because that's one of the things I remember now. It's like Daddy knew. Daddy knew I was going to be OK. And I guess things like that have always been slightly comforting to me now.
这显然对我意义重大，因为那是我现在还记得的事情之一。就像爸爸知道。爸爸知道我会好起来的。我想这些事情到现在对我来说一直都有一点安慰。
If you have a parent like my father, someone who can be so seductive when he wants to be, and so irrational and violent at other times, you spend a long time after they're gone trying to make sense of it all.
如果你有个像我父亲这样的父母——一个在想诱惑你时可以如此迷人，而在其他时候又如此非理性且暴力的人，你在他们离开后的很长一段时间里都会试图弄清楚这一切。
Only recently has those kinds of things changed, just because I've given a lot of thought to it. And I don't even know what to tell people if they ask me about my father. I wouldn't even know where to start or what I would say. Grace, right now, she has a pretty good idea the way she feels. And she looks almost as if she's angry to a certain extent, and sad to another.
直到最近这些想法才有所改变，因为我对此思考了很多。如果别人问起我父亲，我甚至不知道该怎么说。我甚至不知道从哪儿开始，或者该说什么。格蕾丝，现在，她对自己的感受很清楚。她看起来几乎有点愤怒，另一面又很悲伤。
I'm just so indifferent. And indifferent is the worst feeling in the world. It's almost a sin in my eyes to just not care.
我只是感到冷漠。冷漠是世界上最糟糕的感觉。在我看来，不关心甚至是一种罪。
I mean I do care. But it's just so-- I don't. I was lucky enough that it happened early enough in my life that it's not going to make an impact. I don't have a dad. I never really did. Right now, that's the way I've conditioned myself to thinking.
我是说我在意。但太……我不知道。我很幸运，它发生在我人生的早期，所以不会造成什么影响。我没有爸爸。我从来就没有过。现在，我已经让自己适应了这种想法。
By the time I left Sarah, I no longer saw my dad as someone who became a different person with each new wife, in each new decade. What Sarah said was all too familiar. I'd heard and felt all of this before. Looking through the eyes of all my siblings, I saw my father as a person who put on different costumes as the cultural tide changed, who was essentially the same underneath.
当我离开萨拉时，我不再认为爸爸是一个随着每一任新妻子、每一个新十年就变成另一个人的人。萨拉所说的太令人熟悉了。我以前听过也感受过这一切。通过我所有兄弟姐妹的眼睛，我看到父亲是一个随着文化潮流改变而不断更换戏服的人，而本质上他一直没变。
I think my father created a mythology rather than a real life for himself, a series of mythologies, American mythologies. The tortured artist, the rising Hollywood star, the Beat playwright, the Manhattan literary type, the acid-dropping hippie, the '70s hedonist, the conservative born-again, the wandering missionary. Every phase was a new way of mythologizing himself.
我认为父亲为自己创造了神话，而不是真实的生活，一系列神话，美国式神话。受折磨的艺术家、冉冉升起的好莱坞明星、垮掉派剧作家、曼哈顿文学大亨、磕药的嬉皮士、70年代享乐主义者、保守的重生者、流浪的传教士。每一个阶段都是他将自己神话化的新方式。
For all my talk about my dad following his dreams, I think his dreams weren't even his own, but second-hand dreams borrowed from American popular culture. As it changed, so did he. It seemed that he couldn't separate the fantasy of these public myths from real life. In his most personal interactions, he would become D. H. Lawrence, Henry Fonda, Henry Miller, instead of Keith Aldrich.
尽管我常说爸爸在追逐梦想，但我觉得那些梦想甚至不是他自己的，而是从美国流行文化中借来的二手梦想。它变了，他也变了。似乎他无法将这些公共神话的幻想与现实生活区分开。在他最私人的互动中，他会变成D.H.劳伦斯、亨利·方达、亨利·米勒，而不是基思·奥尔德里奇。
In most standard biographies, people change and grow. They face challenges and go through heroic changes. But what happens to the people who get stuck making the same mistakes over and over? For all the surface changes in his life, my father simply put himself in the same situation again and again.
在大多数标准传记中，人们会改变和成长。他们面对挑战并经历英雄般的蜕变。但对于那些陷入不断重复犯同样错误的人来说会发生什么呢？尽管他的一生表面上有种种变化，但我父亲实际上只是不断地把自己投入到同样的境地中。
Here he is writing March 26, 1993. And it's just before your graduation from Boulder. And he says, "Dear Scott. I'm finally brought to a dead stop. Car broken down for the second time in a two-week trip we took to pick up my stuff in California."
这是他在1993年3月26日写的。就在你从博尔德毕业之前。他说：“亲爱的斯科特。我终于到了山穷水尽的地步。我们在去加州取我东西的往返路上，车子修了两次。”
Scott read me a letter Dad wrote him during this last period in his life, just a few months before he died, right after he married his fifth wife, Shirley.
斯科特读了爸爸在生命最后这段时期写给他的一封信，就在他去世前几个月，就在他娶了第五任妻子雪莉之后。
"And of course, I would like for you to know Shirley. The main problem I have had with others is that invariably, after a beginning which implies they are sympathetic with my artistic goals, they expect me to give up those goals and devote myself to building some kind of material estate. But they have actively sought to sidetrack me." Can you believe this?
“当然，我想让你认识雪莉。我与其他人产生的主要问题在于，在一段暗示她们支持我的艺术目标的关系开始后，她们最终都会期待我放弃那些目标，投身于某种物质财富的积累。但她们实际上是在试图阻挠我。”你敢信吗？
No.
不敢。
"I'm aware it will seem odd to you and others who have suffered from some degree of non-support from me. But to me, the 'story of my life'," in quotes, "is one of repeatedly setting aside my work to meet the needs of wives and children." Interesting.
“我知道对于你和其他曾遭受过我某种程度不支持的人来说，这会显得很奇怪。但在我看来，‘我的人生故事’（带引号），是一个为了满足妻子和孩子的需求而反复搁置我的创作的故事。”真有意思。
It's amazing to me that he finds all of these ways to justify himself continually. His whole interpretation of the problems in his life is being somehow him compromising himself with his wives and children. He essentially is blaming them for his inability to be a great artist, which I think is just a bunch of crap.
我感到震惊的是，他能不断找到所有这些方式来为自己辩解。他对自己人生问题的解读方式，似乎是他为了妻子和孩子牺牲了自己。他本质上是在指责她们导致了他无法成为伟大的艺术家，我认为这简直是一堆废话。
My father died in July of 1993. He had just started yet another theater company and married his fifth wife. His relationships with all of his children were strained and distant.
我父亲于1993年7月去世。他刚组建了又一家剧团并娶了第五任妻子。他与所有孩子的关系都紧张且疏远。
I'm Keith Aldrich, the man's second child, first son. Thank you for coming. Dad and I had in common an urge to strike out and wander and do things differently, and sometimes in an unapproved way.
我是基思·奥尔德里奇，这个人的第二个孩子，长子。感谢大家的到来。我和爸爸有一个共同点：那股想要走出去、流浪、以不同方式做事、有时是以未被认可的方式做事的心愿。
This is my father, speaking at his father's memorial service. The way my father talks about his father I think is pretty much the way he'd want to be remembered, the way he'd want me to eulogize him, here on the radio.
这是我父亲，在他父亲的追悼会上发言。我认为父亲谈论他父亲的方式，很大程度上就是他希望被记住的方式，就是他希望我在这电台上悼念他的方式。
He was a heartbroken man. He was a loving man. In his pain, he often struck out at people around him, or was irritated. But it was only out of his pain. He was so close to the Lord, and he was so contrite over the error of his ways.
他是一个心碎的人。他是一个充满爱心的人。在痛苦中，他常伤害周围的人，或是感到愤怒。但这仅仅出自他的痛苦。他离主如此之近，对自己行为的错误感到如此痛悔。
And he endured so much scorn and contempt, and disapproval from people whom he loved so much. And I could share that with him. I knew what that felt like. And he endured it with love in his heart, returned love. And I'm here to honor him, commend his soul to the Lord.
他忍受了如此多的轻蔑、鄙夷，以及来自他深爱之人的不认同。我也能和他感同身受。我知道那种感觉。他以爱、以回报的爱忍受了这一切。我在这里纪念他，将他的灵魂交给主。
In the last few months, meeting with all of my father's children, I've come to know two things for sure. One is that in his own way, he did love each of us. The other is that for all that, none of his children could eulogize him the way he would want. None of us see him the way he saw himself.
在过去的几个月里，与我父亲所有的孩子见过面后，我确实明白了两个道理。一是以他自己的方式，他确实爱我们每一个人。另一是尽管如此，他所有的孩子中没人能以他想要的方式悼念他。我们中没人能以他看待自己的方式看待他。
Gillian Aldrich lives in New York.
吉莉安·奥尔德里奇住在纽约。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors for this show, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from [? Amy Takahara, ?] Jorge Just, Sylvia Lemus, Seth Lind, and Bruce Wallace. The instrumental music in our program today was composed for us by [? Willie Schwartz ?] and performed by Willie on keyboards, Larry Gray on bass, John Rice on guitar, and Douglas Brush on drums.
我们的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。本节目特约编辑：保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林，顾问萨拉·沃威尔。感谢[? 艾米·高桥 ?]、豪尔赫·贾斯特、西尔维娅·莱穆斯、塞斯·林德和布鲁斯·华莱士的制作协助。今天节目中的器乐由[? 威利·施瓦茨 ?]为我们创作，由键盘手威利、贝斯手拉里·格雷、吉他手约翰·赖斯和鼓手道格拉斯·布拉什演奏。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast or listen to our old shows for absolutely free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里您可以获得我们的每周免费播客或免费收听我们以前的节目：www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who I would describe this way.
WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，我会这样描述他。
He enjoys sing-alongs with his guitar, talks freely about sex, makes a living as a computer programmer.
他喜欢弹着吉他唱歌，谈性很开放，靠做电脑程序员谋生。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回归。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。